there is something of a playgrounds fad
going on tonight between two of our
country's top political leaders
President Trump and former Vice
President Joe Biden are arguing over who
could kick the others backside given the
Trump at 71 and Biden is 75 of
pay-per-view cage matches probably out
of the question
correspondent Peter Doocy has reaction
tonight it's like the WWE has taken over
DC round one Tuesday in Miami round two
today on Twitter President Trump punched
back crazy Joe Biden is trying to act
like a tough guy actually he is weak
both mentally and physically and yet he
threatens me for the second time with
physical assault he doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying all the way don't threaten people
Joe this is the closest we've come to
seeing politicians and boxing gloves
since Mitt Romney did it but that was
for charity
this is liberal writers are steamed at
Biden one headline in salon hey Joe
Biden your macho fantasies about a trump
beatdown don't help women there's also a
Washington Post article titled Joe Biden
and the case against toxic masculinity I
do a million of these a day if Biden did
go to the mat with President Trump he
may have a speed advantage as for Trump
we've seen his swing just not in a ring
although his body slamming has been
well-documented it's tough to handicap a
Trump Biden bout so we asked a longtime
friend of the late Muhammad Ali senator
Orrin Hatch for help I feel bad for
buddies flattened right there and right
there in this fight I'm a counter
puncher they go after me I go after them
liberal lawmakers doubt the bout would
turn heads I had two old crotchety
uncles that used to act like that at
family dinners calling each other names
so I just think it's a another example
of that I guess and Republican senators
say this would be far from the Thrilla
in Manilla I don't think that's going to
be a big audience on pay-per-view that's
because as it turns out Trump D Biden
may just be the
under card I'll say this I think Melania
could take them both can you imagine if
we picked a president based on who could
beat up whom it sounds pretty barbaric
but on the plus side it's a lot harder
to hack a boxing ring than a ballot box
Chris Peter Doocy reporting from
ringside and having way too much fun